hold your hand on for a second it's
called digit index ratio yeah you both
have high testosterone how could you
tell based on that so digit index ratio
in utero when you're in your mother's
womb a certain amount of testosterone is
released this is your testosterone
finger this is your estrogen do it on
your dominant hand I have a lot of test
you guys have similar you have pretty
high test you have very high
testosterone people confuse testosterone
they think oh steroids bodybuilding
forget that we're talking about in utero
testosterone it's not perfectly
correlated but it's pretty accurate you
can Google it there's great science on
this it's not palm reading it's not
astrology yeah